for the rami so what brings you here I
want to change and I heard you can help
me speak the straightforward word but I
[Music]
feel like I have this hole that I've
been trying to fill are you praying five
times a day and you check it all five
times a day I've tried to fill it with
sex it only makes things worse I want
you to be my teacher I want to kill my
ego I don't know I'm not just another
one of your desires I don't want to have
sex with you welcome to the path brother
we always talk about being Muslim right
that means we got to help other people
[ __ ] wrong with
she was really hot discipline ramen it's
a muscle it is 2020 they don't want a
man like me anymore they want a man like
you a man who feels a little bit like a
woman but to still officially a man
[Music]
truth is everything is boss we are
forever bound good love compassion
honesty almost know every shower touchy
less masturbated a boy with he must come
to Allah clean everything that's good is
Muslim
it's Muslim soft s like you see [ __ ]
Muslim ya [ __ ] mush I think there's
other ways to learn this though
[Music]
you